[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich sitze hier mit ralf möller
offizieller heimat botschafter des
landes nordrhein westfalen
herr müller sie sind ja heimat
botschafter von einem bundesland wo sie
gar nicht leben es ist nicht so ein
bisschen komisch du ich bin sehr oft
hier
ich bin mindestens so drei vier mal oder
fünfmal im jahr bin ich hier ja aber es
ist ein bisschen ja so als würde man
eine nonne zu sechs beauftragt also ich
war sogar auch mal auf dem kulturmagazin
vom spiegel der nächste
ministerpräsident von nrw von nordrhein
westfalen aber keine angst armin laschet
du machst schon tollen job ja aber den
lastet könnten sie ja windelweich
prügeln wenn sie lust hätten ich bin ja
kein gewalttätiger mensch was müsste ich
machen um heimat botschafterin zu sein
also muss erstmal fit sein
freundlich sein deine heimat erklären
können ja und dann bist du einmal
botschaftern jeder ist ein botschafter
wenn er seiner heimat repräsentiert oder
ganz einfach menschen was erzählt kennen
sie tabu ich habe schon davon gehört
aber ich hab es glaube ich nie richtig
gespielt
sie müssen heimat erklären für die
zuschauer zu hause ohne die wörter zu
hause in schambach lederhosen seehofer
und afd zu verwenden heimat
sie dürfen ja das wort nicht sagen so
was ja so und jetzt spielen wir eine
runde activity
[Musik]
ich habe hier ein paar heimat nahe
begriffe mitgebracht die wir dann beide
für den jeweils anderen pantomimisch
darstellen sollte ja kein problem sein
trauer
spd durchfall
kirche kirche konfirmation
teufelsaustreibung gaga ja es war gut
dann bin ich so wie du bist du werden
lustig wie ertränken oktoberfest
schunkeln nazi sie haben mal gesagt
heimat ist auch erinnerungen wie weit
zurück davon als deutscher in den
erinnerungen damit der heimatbegriff
noch positiv konnotiert ist man kann
schon es ist ganz wichtig klar wir haben
eine eine eine
history aus den die nicht gerade für uns
deutsche immer spricht wo ich aber immer
auch in amerika immer wieder ab und zu
konfrontiert werden nämlich von einem
dritten reich müssen sie dann oft auf
partys sich aktiv vom dritten reich
distanzieren nicht ständig aber
natürlich dass man sagt dann schon mal
zu den deutschen hague
was für eine botschaft haben sie an die
leute aus nordrhein westfalen
die botschaft ist dass sie so bleiben
sollen wie sie sind ehrliche und gerade
menschen die sagen wie es ist wie sie
sich fühlen und diese verbundenheit
bringt mich auch immer wieder gerne
zurück sein fast mehr botschaft als in
all ihren filmen bisher zusammen
ich glaube als maler ist wirklich heimat
botschafter der herzen weil so gut wie
sie das jetzt rüber gebracht haben
können sie gar nicht spielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]